I watched also the louis c.k special and
actually watch at this afternoon it it's
a it's hilarious I mean I laughed he
surprised me so many times and if some
people like most people I think enjoy
Louis CK's a comedian you know the man
is a pervert but he also is a comedy man
and he can beat those two things you
know there's not a rule you can only be
one thing a lot of the news they like to
make you think oh you can only be one
thing buddy
what are you you a milkman or you um you
know are you somebody that whispers a
lot [ __ ] I could do both you know I'm
saying you could be Bill Cosby is he a
pervert rapist seems like that is the
case he's also very entertaining man you
could be both things Louie CK the
special was hilarious man it was
hilarious you know I've never known
Louie I cross paths with him twice he
always seemed like a bit of like a real
cocky kind of dude to me but he is
there's it's just at a different level
man his his is I mean it's [ __ ] good
bro it's [ __ ] good and if I were that
good at comedy dude I would be cocky I
think I mean it is it's just fun it's
also in some parts it's so dark bro it
is dark like it is damn bro I'm
surprised if you looked in there's like
a day I mean it is they could have
filmed black panther during part of it
it's dark bro is dark but it's it almost
forever he reminds me of a distant it's
almost like this dirty Shakespeare
almost he definitely has his in
such contact with a certain point of
view in his head that it's I mean it's
just baffling
and you can never tell if he thinks that
he's because he's always commenting on
himself and I can never tell if he is
amused by himself repulsed or proud and
it's fascinating to not be able to know
that and to listen to him at the same
time you can just you get this there's
this ambiance from him that's just it's
so precisely humanly vulgar almost in a
way or but not just vulgar it's fat it's
it's it's it's hilarious there's gonna
be some dark stuff if you go in there
like oh man um you know if he's as soon
as he says Native American I'm shutting
it off I'm shutting it off ah you know
if you go in there if using an T for
something you probably won't like this
[ __ ] you know if you spend if you were
like a lifetime CNN watch or kind of or
you know if you buy that on a CNN
sweatshirt you probably won't like it
it's just but it's very honest I felt
like it's very honest to a part of our
brain or something that we want to close
or that society wants to close now and I
just thought it was layers does that
mean that I anything else from me
doesn't mean anything else from me it
means that I'm a fewer of his comedy and
that the [ __ ] was [ __ ] really funny
bro and you may have different takes on
it and that's I hope that you do I hope
you have your own take on it and I would
even have to think about it more I just
watched it
but uh but if you're looking for a watch
and it's available on his website and I
you know you know we're not doing any
ads for them or anything or whatever but
but the man is you know any talks about
is you know some of the stuff that
happened and stuff it's interesting it's
certainly it's worth the $8 that's for
dang sure bruh and outside of that Ozark
is those aren't just the same episode
over and over again I feel like every
episode these people just can't [ __ ]
figure it out and the Sun keeps getting
a little bit older
literally the Sun that the the boy they
have is like watching them I mean he
just every episode I feel like he gets
about about two months older which is
pretty fascinating but that's my
thoughts on the louis c.k special
sincerely it's called in and and go
check it out let me know what you think
i think he's probably gonna be the
future where comedians are gonna put
their specials out specifically in a one
locale on their on their own but it was
interesting man I mean it was God there
were some parts whatever the best part
is you're like man I do not I don't it's
not that you don't want he'll get into a
topic you're like oh this is something I
shouldn't be laughing about and then
you're like damn I'm [ __ ] really
laughing about this so then you start to
realize that there's this other thing
and there's this other person inside of
you this other different entity than the
facade that we put on sometimes and that
that entity just likes to laugh and then
it's not as judgmental and it just is
taking things for the value of humor
that's in them and in this special
there's a lot of that it's dark though
dog is dark time don't come at me they
they do it do they if you then that's it
if you don't like it then you don't like
it that's fine nobody else needs to die
don't mean everybody else don't need to
like it that means you don't like it
so gang [ __ ]